[Music]
hey Luke here at the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel and today we are doing
something that I have been planning for
a long long time me and the boys are
huge fans of the river treasure hunting
YouTube channels we love to go out and
watch these family-friendly channels we
guys go and dig and search for things
that people have lost in the rivers and
there's some awesome channels out there
so we've been meaning to get together
with some of our favorite youtubers and
do a river treasure hunting video
however the boys are sick they all got
colds and momma said nope and so it's
just me today but without further ado
let me introduce you to some of the
biggest youtubers out there okay check
this out yeah check it out Brandon J's
channel digging with Jordan and who we
got here
oh yeah bo with aqua Tigger yeah
and right here is none other the Big D
Jake with D almighty say hi to everyone
Jake so today we're gonna be doing
something a little bit different okay
you guys have seen tons and tons of
River treasure videos so today we are
going to be searching for couch treasure
yeah we're in a spot where people lose
tons of stuff under the couches and
we're gonna go diving for it you guys
ready if you guys want to see more couch
treasure videos make sure to crunch that
like button guys don't forget to leave a
comment to think of that tell us what
you think we're gonna find ready to do
this yeah alright you might find a
machine gun that'd be pretty awesome hey
Bo why don't you show us our equipment
what do you got what do you got here
these are floaties yeah and Brandon what
what you got on what okay you guys got
flippers okay yeah and we got we got
ourselves some bags cuz inevitably we
find a lot of trash and so we're gonna
try to clean things up a little bit and
we're gonna pick up any toys and trash
we find along the way well before we get
started we gotta get some sunscreen on
Brandon J here he is very fair-skinned
it burns quite easily so let's get him
going you two both all right that's the
last of the sunscreen you guys ready
let's go alright guys we're gonna start
off by diving over here this is a place
that's frequented by a lot of people who
lose stuffs really murky low visibility
conditions though so we're gonna be
bringing our spotlights and really
taking our time down there all right
guys just checking my regulator and yeah
we're seem to be all ready to go you
guys where did you dive on this thing
alright let's do it guys let's see what
we can find you ready I find everyone
yeah you ready to dig yeah get down in
there oh you found a lobster look at
that oh yeah here we go
[Music]
oh look at this oh my goodness show it
show the camera will get that what is
that that is that is an iPhone and
original iPhones that's a great fine Oh
[Music]
see if it even works Oh
oh my gosh Brandon what did you find
show everybody Oh Kindle baby well if
someone lost a Kindle under here and it
still works look at that it's got a
little bit of screen damage but the
batteries works fine show me your Hot
Wheels car wash Oh I've been wondering
where that is you put it in your back
the Kindles playing again are you gonna
put your kid too low away Brandon Oh
Jake Jake Jake dude dude don't don't eat
the river treasure don't hold on nope
don't eat that you got oh yeah
Curious George awesome we'll put that in
there what look at that that is a
Pokemon toy look at that
yeah that's like a little a little
skateboard okay
Oh big circus book oh look at this
yeah hey Jacob take it look like a
beachy what'd you find oh that's it soup
you guys found some super Wings a pair
of them look at that super Wings awesome
oh the coolest fine we got Oh a lego
ninja turtle all right you gotta define
what is that oh my goodness
it's a pinhead looking at about a minion
here
where'd you find oh my goodness
yeah that's Yoshi ah nice police cars Oh
another super Wings it's a rainbow trout
gonna let the fish go oh look hey a
bottle hey Jake lights the clicked
bottles so there you go buddy well we
had a pretty epic trip and we found a
lot of stuff way more stuff than we
could show you so we got the highlights
I was a little disappointed we didn't
find a pair of Oakley's I was really
hoping for that but we found some pretty
cool finds so check this out yeah yeah
bo found this awesome phone look at this
this yeah it still works is that crazy
it's gonna wake a little crack screen
but it still works now one of my
favorite finds was the Roku remote cuz
I've been looking for that for a long
time we're gonna try to find the owner
of this iPhone we're gonna go ahead and
try to charge it up and see if we can
fix it up and find out who it belongs to
good news me and Brandon were able to
track down the owner of the phone and
we're gonna be able to give back her
phone unfortunately Big D had to take
off a little bit early and so he's off
getting a nap but listen guys we hope
you enjoyed this video crushed that like
button click subscribe leave a comment
tell us what your favorite find is and
don't forget to check out digging with
Jordan aqua and DL my teas
youtube channels some great videos guys
and remember don't forget to click
subscribe to the outdoor boys youtube
channel we put out new videos every
Saturday morning so thanks for watching
guys
take care